c'est ce soir vous le savez la fête de
la musique à paris comme dans toutes les
grandes villes de province et les petits
villages laurence donnera un grand
concert en solo avenue montaigne ce soit
les nombres les entrées 11,2 ouvre
l'antenne à 20h45 avec maggie et ses
invités n'ont point avec taratata france
2 quitte la capitale pour l'ambiance
très chaude du sud de la france la liste
des invités très impressionnante julien
clerc que nougaro liane foly poweo entre
autres et les autres autre grand rendez
vous pour les parisiens l'hymne ô des
nations dans la cour d'honneur des
invalides 600 musiciens 200 choristes
rendre hommage à verdi on entendra
notamment le compact d'aïda voici un
extrait de la répétition
beaucoup
un genre le berre est avec nous en
direct de la bourse de paris l'opéra
vous connaissez vous gens